and welcome to Hannity and we begin
tonight with the Fox News Alert Israel
tonight is at War a fight for its very
survival after a barbaric terrorist
attack an invasion by Hamas the
deadliest attack in that country's
[Music]
history allahar
allahar
and you heard in that video as women and
children are being taken hostage Allah
abbar now in just a minute we're going
to take you live to the ground where our
very own Trey yank is standing by in
southern Israel tonight we also
monitoring the situation in Northern
Israel where Hezbollah has directed A
barrage of rockets into Israel we'll
also have a close eye on Gaza the Hamas
stronghold that is now smoldering after
massive bombing campaign by by Israel
and it's only the beginning we are told
that a fullscale ground Invasion with
well over 100,000 troops many is
possibly as many as 300,000 is now
imminent Israel is fighting back against
what is a Savage enemy that wants to
wipe them off the planet over the
weekend Hamas terrorists they stormed
Southern Israel they did it by air Land
and Sea they parag glided into a music
festival where they slaughtered at least
260 young unarmed concert goers and
including one 30-year-old woman whose
naked body was paraded around by Hamas
terrorists while they were filming and
cheering and chanting once again Allahu
abbar uh quote interpretation God is
great other civilians including children
they were bound they were beaten they
were taken as hostages in this video a
young woman is covered in blood thrown
into the back of a Jeep by several
terrorists yeah more chance of Allah
abbar and other Hamas terrorists went
door to door in local towns taking
hostages murdering entire families
shooting family pets setting homes on
fire and in one hometown by the way in
one home uh to just over a thousand
people that's over 100 dead bodies were
just recovered there are also reports
that Hamas filming some of the more
gruesome murders with the victim's own
phones and then uploading that footage
to the victims social media platforms
for all of their family and friends to
see pretty evil one such video
reportedly showing hamash shooting a
little girl in front of her parents and
then taking the rest of the family
hostage and also breaking today Hamas is
now openly threatening to execute
hostages on camera and that would
include American citizens that are
hostage including the nine that we have
confirmed that are dead Americans dead
as a result of this attack the Rolling
Stone magazine is now reporting tonight
that dozens of Americans are now being
held in Gaza by terrorists and so far
well actually that figure has gone to 11
Americans among the 1100 men women and
children murdered by Hamas during the
initial attack and tonight Israel
doesn't just have the right to fight
back they have an obligation to
eliminate every single member of Hamas
and obliterate them you want to look at
this proportionately well more people
were killed in this full-scale terrorist
Invasion than during 9/11 many have been
saying this is Israel's 9/11 but if you
look at the amount of people who live in
Israel this would be similar to killing
more than 35,000 Americans in one day on
2,977 Americans were slaughtered that
day many thereafter with 9/11 related
illnesses but you do know what the Biden
Administration you know what their first
instinct was to tell Israel oh please
stand down just accept your fate look at
this now deleted tweet from the weekend
quote we urge all Ides to refrain from
violence and retaliatory attacks Terror
and violence solve nothing all sides
excuse me retaliatory attacks oh you
can't buy back all right did Hamas write
that tweet or do the people that work in
the Biden White House are they really
just that stupid if anyone ever killed
the equivalent of of 35,000 plus
Americans you don't think you would want
your government to strike back with with
a fierce uh
a fierce intensity the likes of which
nobody's ever seen before because I know
that would be my reaction and today your
so-called president he was nowhere to be
found he seemingly just took the day off
White House they called the lid that
means you will not be hearing from the
president again for the rest of the day
at about noon today if you want to be
exact 11:51 a.m. Biden then attempted to
shamelessly capitalize on these attacks
oh guess what we got about an hour ago a
news dump releasing a statement
confirming that Joe Biden has been
questioned by the special counsel over
his mishandling of classified documents
how convenient to do it when we're on
the verge of an allout War Israel is now
at war with Hamas and all their related
organizations and get this Biden
actually hosted a big party and a
barbecue with a live band American
citizens they're being tortured they're
being murdered in Gaza and our greatest
Ally in the Middle East reels from an
unprecedented a terrorist attack and Joe
Biden's having a cookout pretty sick but
it gets worse in 2021 Joe Biden sent
nearly 400 million us tax dollars to the
Palestinian Authority despite concerns
from officials that money would boost
Hamas and result in more terror attacks
well more recently Biden gifted Iran
remember that special deal the $6
billion that they took out of uh what
was a South Korean bank and moved it
into a cutter Bank after asking asking
the mullers to to pinky promise that
they would only spend it on humanitarian
uh projects even though the president of
Iran roundly rejected that publicly on
NBC apparently no one in the Biden
Administration not our dumb president or
vice president or Secretary of State
seem to realize money is fungible what
does that mean in other words okay you
take money that they would otherwise
have to spend themselves and that frees
them up to continue to be the world's
number one state sponsor of terrorism so
it is no surprise that Iran spent weeks
helping Hamas plan orchestrate this
massive attack according to a report
this weekend in the Wall Street Journal
that's right including the Iranian
revolutionary guard now of course Iran
we know they're the number one state
sponsor of Terror and we know they've
always funded Hamas and Hezbollah
doesn't matter Shia Sunni they don't
care as long as they go after Israel and
several other terrorist groups in the
Middle East but for some reason
Democrats are obsessed with giving them
money and eliminating sanctions and now
we see the results we see death
suffering chaos and your so-called
president well he checked out before
noon today and meanwhile Israel Israeli
president or prime minister Netanyahu
probably the only leader on the world
stage today that has the moral Clarity
that's needed for Just A Moment Like
This tonight he is vowing to protect the
world's only Jewish state from these
barbaric terrorists who want to push
Israel into the sea take a look Israel
is at War we didn't want this war it was
forced Upon Us in the most brutal and
Savage way but though Israel didn't
start this war Israel will finish it
Kamas will understand that by attacking
us they've made a mistake of historic
proportions we will exact a price that
will be remembered by them and Israel's
other enemies for decades to come The
Savage attacks that Hamas perpetrated
against innocent Israelis are
mindboggling slaughtering families in
their homes massacring hundreds of young
people at an outdoor
Festival kidnapping scores of women
children and elderly even Holocaust
survivals Kamas terrorists bound burned
and executed children they are
savages Hamas is Isis and just as the
forces of civilizations United to defeat
is
the forces of civilization must support
Israel in defeating
Hamas prime minister Netanyahu he knows
what must be done Israel will now wage a
fullscale war against H Hamas and make
no mistake about this he will win that
war there is no other choice the this is
a fight for Israel's survival and in
just the past few minutes by the way uh
we have seen explosions now in Gaza City
a little after 4 a 4 am. their time hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else